claude girard bonjour bonjour le suroît
merci nous avoir écrit absolument vous
aviez fait la demande alors on a répondu
à votre proposition on est très content
là ils devaient avoir une tete l'on
n'aurait pu patiner derrière ça vous
vous demandez qu'est ce qui est long
comme ça de faire la belle patinoire
oui surtout que pendant l'été 2010 9
j'étais ici est un travailleur m'avait
juré il monsieur girard je vous jure que
vous aller patiner sur les semaines est
clair qu en décembre 2019 et ben là je
pense que c'est un très bon policier
parce que y'a pas tenu sa promesse
alors je sais ça que je voudrais savoir
en iran d'où dans l'évolution de ce
chantier qui est quand même commencé
depuis 2010 est que moi je me souviens
les images de l'ancien maire de près
souriez c'est un très beau projet avec
les terrasses avec que la la la
promenade qui va se rasseoir patinoire
en hiver et moi j'ai surtout hâte quand
est-ce que je vais pouvoir venir patiner
dans cet espace qui est merveilleux qui
va servir aussi d'ouverture de l'est
pour le le quartier des spectacles la
dernière phase là bravo bonne question
on va aller demander à la ville
j'attends la réponse merci bonjour tu as
lu
me beaudry ce coderre avait annoncé sa
deux ans de retard qu est ce qui arrive
en fait est arrivé plein de choses il y
avait déjà eu des retards avant la
copine le contracteur avait déjà eu
quelques semaines de retard
on avait trouvé une stratégie de bonus
pour qu'ils puissent terminer la
patinoire pour 2019 ça n'a pas
fonctionné il ya pour réussir à
rattraper son retard qui après bien
évidemment les faits commis dans l'ue
cette semaine d'arrêt du chantier puis
après le bal les travailleurs ont dû
commencer à réapprendre à travailler
selon les distanciation les nouvelles
règles sanitaires
mais la coved arrêté cette semaine
chantier c'est tout sauf que l'on garde
de deux ans wen mais après ce qui s'est
passé aussi c'est les nouvelles normes
une nouvelle façon de travailler et
c'est un projet aussi quand même une
plusieurs complexité on vient travailler
dans le souterrain
on vient couler une dalle de béton home
est un système de réfrigérer c'est quand
même de l'inédit as tu grande échelle
donc c'est un projet qui est quand même
relativement complexe est ce qu'il ya eu
des pépins techniques vraiment vous êtes
creuser la tête là ce point là les coûts
ont été des perso c'est sûr que les
coûts augmentent on parle d'un projet
d'environ entre 75 et 78 millions au
final
mais après c'est sûr que yo les retards
de chantier où il ya des malus qui sont
imposés aussi par jour de retard de
chantier
donc à la fin il y aura une évaluation
qui se fait du coût total du chantier on
dit avec le contracteur comme j'ai pour
l'instant on évalue entre 75 à 68
millions pour tout chantier bon à quel
moment on patine là à le moment où on
patine c'est sensé d'être à l'automne
prochain
donc on espère que la place et elle va
être ouverte en juillet en juillet on
prévoit l'ouverture de la place donc on
va pas se promener sur la grand place
après on va tester le système de
réfrigération et à l'automne prochain on
va pouvoir recommencer à patiner que
vous êtes ont disposé on va là et vous
vous garder une petite gêne que je suis
plus dur et oui à l'automne prochain au
vatican sur la place henri tranquille à
rendre hommage à ce libraire
extraordinaire qu'avait cette belle mais
tout à fait pire en fait ça fait un clin
d'oeil à la librairie tranquille qui est
vraiment un lieu où plusieurs auteurs de
la culture québécoise se sont réunis
c'est aussi là où a été lancée le refus
global donc vraiment ça fait aussi en
clair
d'oeil à la révolution tranquille voilà
donc en pleine campagne électorale
municipale on va venir patiner en pleine
campagne électorale
on va donc voir vos patiner à l'automne
prochain oui effectivement je vous dis
merci merci à vous